well one thing that could help with that
shortage of trade school here in Las
Vegas it's expanding across the country
as well we take a look at the
skyrocketing enrollment increase for the
skilled trades and this particular
program
MTI the National Technical Institute
trains men and women in the trades HVAC
electrical and plumbing we've done
numerous stories about how enrollment
skyrocketed during and after the
pandemic and why this program is so
successful the curriculum is designed by
contractors which means people
graduating these programs get
entry-level positions to start working
right away and because it's so efficient
CEO Ryan Woodward says people attend NTI
from 46 out of the 50 states and because
that demand is growing we added in
another building this year into our
Nevada campus for those coming from
neighboring states Woodward says NTI has
created a better way to make the trade
school programming more accessible we've
condensed it down to where they can
watch all the instruction on video at
home and then they come to our campus on
a Friday and Saturday
and do all of their labs and do that
over a two-month period and they can
graduate it makes it very convenient for
these other communities where people
don't necessarily have a trade school
they can come here and get the exact
same training and go back there and work
what's more NTI is opening a brand new
Campus in Houston Texas here's a look to
help with demand from the East Coast
somebody was going to come out of school
like this they're they're starting pay
is going to be somewhere probably
between 15 and 20 an hour
they're going to do that for a little
while while they're gaining the skill
set on the job so they'll apply what
they learn from school
and then they'll get that quickly and be
able to go out in the field and then
from there the sky's a limit
what word adds the more jobs they
complete the more money they make